unsurprisingly Blue Beetle is based on a
variety of DC comic stories that might
be fun to revisit if you're a fan the
Jaime Reyes version of Blue Beetle first
appeared in the Infinite Crisis event in
2006. in the series Jaime is recruited
by Booster Gold and Batman to help spot
the Rogue AI brother I because Jaime's
Scarab is the only thing that can see it
their goal is to stop brother I before
it can assimilate all of Earth's
metahumans according to director Angel
Manuel Soto Blue Beetle graduation day
actually took inspiration from the Blue
Beetle movie by incorporating elements
such as Jaime's High School graduation
Palmyra City and Victoria cord into the
DC Comics Mythos it proved that
sometimes live action media dictates the
comics not always the other way around
the director also cited the video game
Injustice 2 as an inspiration as well as
the 2011 New 52 Comics relaunch for the
specific design of Jaime's alien suit